يعيد الابن الضال
سيف الإسلام القذافي ، نجل
الديكتاتور الليبي السابق ماما القذافي ، الذي أمضى
العقد الماضي بعيدًا عن الأنظار إلى حد كبير ،
لكنه الآن يتراجع مرة أخرى إلى دائرة
الضوء التي كان والده
يُعلن ترشيحه للرئاسة
[موسيقى] و
المظهر المحسوب المصمم
لتذكير الليبيين بأن والده
يقلد أسلوبه وسلوكياته
لسنوات ، كان يُنظر إلى سيف على أنه
المصلح الغربي المثقف الذي يمكنه
إحداث تغيير في بلد
حكمه والده لأكثر من 40 عامًا
ولكن عندما ثار الليبيون ضد
نظام القذافي في عام 2011  ظل سيف
مخلصًا ، وقد اعتقلته قوات المتمردين في
صحراء ليبيا الجنوبية بعد أسابيع قليلة من مقتل
القذافي بوحشية ،
وأطلقت الميليشيا سراحه بعد ست
سنوات بموجب قانون عفو عام ، لك
ه كان لا يزال مطلوبًا من قبل السلطات في
رابلس حيث حكمت عليه محكمة با
إعدام.  في
2015. واليوم
تتهمه المحكمة الجنائية الدولية بارتكاب جرائم
ضد الإنسانية لـ h  يُزعم
تورطه في حملة القمع الدموية التي شنها والده
ضد المتظاهرين في
ليبيا منذ
سقوط القذافي مع تنافس أحزاب متعددة
على السلطة ،
ومن بينها هذا الرجل المنشق
الجنرال خليفة حفتر
الذي قاد ذات مرة حملة عسكرية استمرت 10 أشهر
للاستيلاء على طرابلس من المدعومة من أم.
الحكومة وفرضت حصارًا على العاصمة
الآن ينضم إلى القذافي الآمن في
سباق رئاسي مثير للجدل.
أعلنت ترشيحي
للانتخابات الرئاسية ليس للسلطة أو
بحثًا عن مكانة بل لقيادة
شعبنا في مرحلة حاسمة نحو
الازدهار والتقدم
ونجاح الانتخابات.  من المقرر عقده في
الرابع والعشرين من كانون الأول (ديسمبر) لكن هذا التاريخ قد
يتغير وعلى الرغم من الدعم العام من
المجتمع الدولي يخشى العديد من الليبيين من
أنهم لن يكونوا أحرارًا ولا نزيهين
، ومع وجود هذين الشخصين المثيرين للانقسام الذي
يرى الكثيرون أنهما المرشحان الأولان ، فإن
الانتخابات قد لا تفعل شيئًا يذكر  تهدئة
عدم الاستقرار السياسي والاقتتال الداخلي
الذي عاث الخراب في البلاد
على مدى السنوات العشر الماضية  ارس بيكي اندرسون cnn
ابو ظبي